nella mia cucina e allora visto che
questa cosa non ci ha creduto nessuno
perché io non so fare
luca cucina non si può dire cucinare
sono qua col mio amico alfonso che mi
viene in soccorso perché se no sarei
morto che non saprei mangiare perché
vivo da solo purtroppo milan primo amico
alfonso e scienze dove faremo una scelta
dello yorkshire pagina allora tu che sei
originari di york 16 nov l use all of
chiude gli occhi al palatrincone tu
pensa il caino è un è un po di farina
budina o non lo è non è il si nota
bonino di fare il paddling tradotto in
italiano e budino maurino ma non lo è
perché a york share
non conosco io conosco solo dei cani non
è altro che un contorno che loro usano
torna e compagni azione un
accompagnamento
ok si usa nelle campagne degli utilizzi
uno esaminare campagna di young alle
campagne usiamola che questo vestito
appunto per accompagnare il roast beef è
arrivata per prima cosa prendiamo l'ex
take that would be bop forse le sex on
fire in app engine debon e cioè avenue
back my one and again and put this in
altri blog
mai una volta che ci siamo sporcati con
la nuova lexus bravo sull'ex professori
flusso ai prossimi brena un weekend
buxom mio insiders ai aromatizzato
aromatizzato like the book and in the
sims ragazzi hanno latte
no no no sto scherzando il latte roma
video giocate a the sims per favore che
l'hanno al nur dlc al latte aromatizzato
nel mucchio e non so cos'altro aggiunge
comunque inside the lich king spot with
e all'it olio pasta un altro tipo flat e
che ferma detiene thank il suo centro
stimolo si ricevono dello yorkshire
thank you so much the boy il drappo il
jack alfonso m
but it here and reverse di
quest'operazione di essere quanto più
veloce fosse una second perché l'mc week
end dal giorno
adesso andiamo a mettere subito in forno
a 200 30 gradi per proteggere i tre
minuti
sicuramente quanto 15 15 e capaci con
questo conserva lo conserva come
possibile questa come come come con che
magia e un milan aveva fatto da fatto
giampieri inediti ngf a buonissimo no
ragazzi incredibile sono state o
complimenti ad alfonso che è riuscito a
farmi fare un piatto pazzesco che non
avrei mai saputo neanche immaginare anni
a testa infatti quando uscito mi sembra
strano forse perché fatto tutto tu però
noi ci abbiamo messo tanto temperata
però sai dove se ci si mette ancora meno
a farlo e se ho ragazzi su the scenes
vita di campagna perché effettivamente
il mio ragazzo qua non so fare la pasta
strane ma questo non sa fare nulla non
sa cucinare ma neanche farsi il bagno
normalmente prima di cucinare il nostro
palmi volevo andare perché l'ultima
volta che sono andato qua avrebbe
proprio senso che tu cercarsi di farti
degli amici almeno amici contadini
eccolo là ho fregato al posto con la
pulzella chi va a roma perde la coppa
del degli europei quindi vattene
ski simo scott devia fuori alle palle
presentazione divertente subito a
rimorchiare come il buon faris a fare
anche in vita campagna la ragazza svolge
uno sguardo folle c'è veramente da
questa quale cucino tutti i padri che
vuole questo qualsiasi tutto con uno
specchio
cosa stai facendo zio a non è uno
specchio sta lavorando a maglia
piccioncini io dovrei fare il pad in
visto che comunque volevo fare vedere
forze che so fare pagine non è proprio
una cosa minima anzi visita il bar
bellissima e poi dritti al party in
ragazzi ma perché è un successi ma chi
te l'ha detto nulla ci potesse esistere
katrina sarebbe la mia mogliettina sono
proprio il rapper comunque poi volevo
ordinare una birra ordina una bevanda la
b anzi teatini che tipo martini ma con
la pera quanto felice di servire bene va
bene grazie
sai che so fare di baldini pazzeschi
nostre tre va bene fa il giocoliere o il
barman va bevilo ok bravissimo torno a
casa come marlena perfetto con cecilia
con cecilia con cecilia con cecilia al
si torna a casa con cecilia ragazzi e si
rimorchia easy colpa ding e cecilia sta
in casa ed qualche faccio vedere il
parking cucina quando potrebbe fare il
pan de umberto ma faremo il padre però
facciamo dell'amico alfonso come si fa
il paddling ragazzi al palo ti faccio
vedere come si prepara a yorkshire
pudding che tu magari non lo sai però
faccio vedere partito già rimorchiato in
questa casa con le mani più tardi si può
da fa anche il pan de muertos napoli
tutti i giorni ma io tesissimo baldin
dello yorkshire ok rothschild fighting
ok farina latte a uovo aceto e tu e io
avrei usato il latte questa farina il
latte può innesco intervistare bullismo
buono vediamo un po come fare secondo me
va bene se prendo all'olio deprima del
motore che non è quello neofita in
cucina comunque niente ma questo però
però almeno meno
stava dicendo che questo non era meglio
dell'atleta è uscito si esce sempre e
poi lo mette sempre c'era già il partito
come il nostro uguale c'è uscito fuori
uguale parte c'è quell'altro acquisita
l'abilità di videogioco che sa che sono
io
ok allora io vorrei servire balding
perché la zia e non so se si sommano
genere nostri perché come i fatti perché
secondo me gli altri se ne mangiati
mentre posava il piazzale ha un po per
uguale o cioè molto se è molto simile
qualità eccellente famosa addirittura
eccellente piatti vegetariani mia fa
pazzesco e ha variato tra nove ore
questa sta nel mio accesso a far finta
di fare rocky balboa però fanini germi
nel cesso
nello stesso tempo non è proprio in modo
più elegante di servire un pali però
vabbè prova a mangiarmi infatti non
mancano sono bagnato in area rivederci e
stato un bel fatti se n'è andata perché
lo sto mangiando io sarei andato ora
devo proprio andare grazie per la
compagna ci vediamo dove si è offesa si
offesa si offenda ma infatti anche
giampiero rimane per quanti sono sei
mangiato noi no sì sono io nel mesagne
ragazzi quindi se volete fare yorkshire
palin con alphonse ci abbiamo messo un
po di più se avrete più facilmente su
the sims farina o uovo uno dei due
consigli la farina che più facile
prendere altri 100 e seguiteci io vi
ringrazio e ci siamo subito un bacio
[Musica]